another installment of
an ayah a deeper understanding
in this installment we are going to be
speaking about another verse
which is found in surat al-baqarah
this verse is one of the first verses
of the quran in which allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala commands all of humanity
notice this verse contains
the first command to of allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala in the quran
and this verse contains the first
prohibition
of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in the
entire quran
so the first do and the first do not
is found in these two verses
it's actually two verses but they are
connected in meaning so
they're almost considered one verse
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in the
21st and 22nd
verse of surah
o people o humanity o human beings and
jin kind alike
worship your lord allah
worship your lord the one who has
created you all
and those who have preceded you in order
that you may
attain safety in order that you may
attain
sanctuary from allah subhanahu ta'ala
salvation
from the hell fire protection
he says subhana ta'ala describing
the one who has made
for you all the earth as
a kind of carpeting as a
surface for you to live on it's not too
hard to where you cannot benefit from it
it's not too soft to where it is too
malleable
and you can't walk on it or be it be of
use to you
but it isn't it is the it is the
bedrock upon which you live he says
and the one who has made and provided
you all with the
sky as a kind of
canopy above you all
he says subhanahu
and he sent down from the heavens water
and from this water he has sprung forth
for you
all sustenance bounty
he has sprung forth for you all fruits
vegetables vegetation he has nourished
you all with this water
he says
so do not associate unto allah
anything similar what does this mean
meaning do not make anything similar to
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in your
worship of he
is
so do not ascribe unto allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
any similars don't make anything
similar to allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in
worship
he says subhanahu ta'ala while you know
that it is only he who nourishes you
it is only he who provides you it is
only he who has brought you into
existence
hence it is only he who is worthy of
your worship
subhanahu wata'ala so these two verses
contain the first command of allah in
all of the quran
worship your lord and these the two
verses contain the first prohibition of
allah
and do not associate unto allah
any similars now what does that mean
notice here how allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala makes the calling
o people this is a call to
all of humanity anyone who hears this
and is able to comprehend it
this applies to him
o people because that is what human
beings were created
for we were created to worship allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
alone without any partners
says in the closing verses
and i have not created the jin kind and
the humankind
except so that they may worship me that
is the only reason that they have been
created
and so allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
focuses the call on everyone generalizes
it
and he says
worship your lord what is worship
worship is only what allah subhanahu
ta'ala deems to be worship
if allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala has not
deemed it as
worship it is invalid and this is what
is is referred to in islam as
which is innovation innovation is when a
person tries to get closer to allah
and worship allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
with something that allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has not allowed him to worship
him with
that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has not
instructed through his prophet and his
messenger muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam that's the
definition of
innovation is when a person tries to
gain
nearness to allah in a way that allah
has not
legislated that allah has not allowed
that allah has not instructed
through his prophet and messenger
[Arabic recitation]
likewise worship of allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is only
valid when it is directed to him
alone without any partners when allah
worship your lord what he subhanahu
what's
essentially saying is if you worship
anyone or anything else along with allah
you have not worshipped allah a good way
to think of this and we discussed this
before
in previous installments of this series
a good way to think about this is
we all know what prayer is when a person
prays they begin with allah akbar and
they end it with a tesleem
to the right and to the left if a person
were to come and pray
but they don't have knowingly
would we consider this to be prayer the
answer is no this is not prayer
it looks prayer but it's invalid
because one of its conditions is missing
and its condition is that a person be in
a state of taharah
in a state of spiritual purity that a
person has will do
if a person does not have then this is
not considered
no matter how eloquent or how good it is
in itself
likewise is the issue of worship the
worship of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
it is only considered worship
when it is directed only to allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala alone without any
partners and i'd to
at this occasion share with you a
narration of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam this narration is found
in
[Silence]
says
that allah has said what is referred to
as al hadith
he says i am least in need of a partner
whoever worships me and ascribes a
partner
unto me in that worship i will forsake
him
and forsake his partnership his
worship
i will leave him and i will leave his
his worship i will reject it i will
reject him and reject that worship
and so in order for it to be considered
to be worship
it has to be a only for the sake of
allah subhanahu ta'ala
only directed to allah and be
it has to be in the way that allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has instructed
so when allah says he's essentially
saying worship me
alone worship me only in the way that
the prophet my prophet muhammad has told
you to worship me
now we go on to the prohibition
the prohibition do not ascribe unto
allah
any and dead and dead is gemma is plural
for nid
an enid in the arabic language is
someone who is similar to someone else
so he's saying subhanahu wa ta'ala do
not
ascribe unto me or make
similar to me anything or anyone else
what does that mean well that means that
when someone worships
allah and worships another along with
allah
in that sense he is essentially saying
this is equal to allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
and that is the essence of shirk
that is the essence of what we have been
prohibited
as human beings and that is the
unforgivable sin
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
indeed allah does not forgive
that any partners be associated unto him
that worship that is directed to him be
directed to anyone else as well
so this negates worship of other than
allah
and affirms worship only for allah
so what is the first commandment of the
quran
the first commandment of the quran in
short
is that is the first thing we've been
commanded
essentially essentially the first
commandment of the quran
is none is rightfully worship but allah
alone without any partners and that
anyone or anything that is worshipped
other than allah subhanahu wa it is an
invalid worship
and it is the gravest of sin that the
human being can commit
this is the first command of the quran
this is the first prohibition of the
quran
this is what allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
starts out the remainder of the quran
with
an an an absolute
command to all of humanity
that they worship him alone without any
partners
and a general prohibition that anything
be made
similar to allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in
any way
we discussed in our previous
installments
we discussed surah cafe roon
we discussed
and we mentioned that these two chapters
together
we derive from them the two types of
tahit
likewise there are two types of
there is that when allah subhanahu when
a person makes something similar to
allah in their worship of that thing
or when someone makes something similar
to allah
in the names and attributes of allah
meaning they make something similar to
allah and
his names and attributes just as there
are two types of taheed
there are two types of shikh the
scholars have also
divided shikh into two types
they mention major and minor shikh
is what takes a person out of the fold
of islam
worshiping other than allah subhanahu wa
and minor shirk is
something that has reverence that is
only befitting for allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
but it will not take a person out of the
fold of islam
and this is a topic which is very broad
and deserves its own installments insha
allah
which inshallah one day we will get to
and we'll be able to
communicate all of this knowledge
that
the quran and the sunnah has provided us
through
our scholars and our deep and rich
history of scholarship throughout the
centuries
we ask allah subhanahu wa that he teach
us of his book
what we are ignorant of that he make us
to remember
what we have been made to forget of his
book that he teach us wisdom
from his book that he benefit us from
that wisdom
and whoever is given wisdom then that
person has been given a great thing
a great giving and a great gift from
allah
my
you